[Musique]
notre ca ce soir diane bérard nicolas
duvernois bonsoir à vous deux
bombardiers encore bombardier mais là
c'est une étape importante quand même
que la vente de bombardier transport et
alstom
diane bérard d'abord est ce que c'est un
triste jour on perd bombardier transport
mon contraire on assure l'avenir de
bombardier transport avec la caisse de
dépôt qu'il devient quand même le
premier actionnaire d'alstom
mais je me sens plus pragmatique que
nostalgique aujourd'hui alors je pense
aux employés les employés devant garder
de bons emplois bien payés des gens qui
paie des impôts québec qui vont
consommer au québec je pense que on
s'attend à rien de revenir sur toutes
les mauvaises décisions qui ont été
prises dans le passé
soyons pragmatiques et pense aux emplois
qui sont sauvées bon je vous et vous je
n'ai vu pencher la tête nicolas vous
vous preniez la tête à deux mètres non
mais ça me fait penser un peu aux
mexique télésérie qui s'appelle
telenovelas wii et ses éternelles la
main ni dur pendant quatre ans quand
j'ai envie de prendre une frappe de van
fournier pas son prochain appel c'est
comme mascotte la chine plus mais je ne
partage absolument tout ce que diana dis
moi ma seule priorité c'est les employés
les contractants et leurs employés de
bombardier transport mais chut sommes
plus capables on n'est plus capable de
tout à fait raison mais qui s'est drogué
sont les actionnaires
1h45 d'action le way mais ce que je vois
surtout un chaudron où il fut le fleuron
peut-être là peu importe québécois
partir ça c'est sûr et certain que c'est
toujours triste et puis surtout du fait
qu' ils ont été obligés de vendre et
c'est pas comme s'il voulait vendre
vous savez bien vous savez gérald les
parties prenantes c'est pas juste des
actionnaires dans les employés sont des
parties prenantes ici
donc quand on pense aux parties
prenantes on pense pas juste aux
actionnaires je pensais pas jouer aux
actionnaires
autre sujet québec ne veut pas fermer
l'économie de nouveau et ce serait un
désastre du pire fait buzz aujourd'hui
ce serait une catastrophe a dit le
premier ministre
legault aujourd'hui pour l'économie
nicolas d'abord votre réaction là dessus
mais le premier confinement nous a mis à
genoux donc en 2ème confinement
normalement ça nous couperait la tête ça
hallucinant quel point ça a affecté
l'économie et un deuxième confinement
non seulement ça va affecter l'économie
mais je crois qu'il va voir aussi à un
retour du balancier où ça va aussi
affecter normes aimant pour pas
sous-estimer le côté psychologique
autant des entrepreneurs des employés
que les personnes qui doivent reprendre
en guimet leurs enfants à la maison tout
en gardant leur travail
un deuxième contrôle jean mances est à
éviter pour le gouvernement sur tout cas
il faut toujours qu'il ya un coupable
même si pas de leur faute mais beaucoup
de personnes j'en suis convaincu qu'ils
mettraient la faute sur le dos du
gouvernement donc deuxième confinement
c'est non non non partout ouais mais là
mettre la faute sur le gouvernement
c'est à dire qui on regarde les chiffres
on regarde les tendances on regarde les
craintes de deuxième de deuxième vague
bien sûr d'y emmener ce que celui fermer
de nouveau l'économie est ce que c'est
inévitable dans le fond c'est une grosse
deuxième vague par exemple au mois de
novembre
il faut y aller de façon chirurgicale
moi je m'inquiète beaucoup au niveau de
la santé mentale des impacts
psychologiques qui vont inclure pour des
années donc je compte sur le
gouvernement pour y aller de façon
chirurgicale
hockey québec aujourd'hui le
gouvernement du québec a annoncé une
nouvelle contribution au panier bleus et
quand on parle d'économie puis de
relance économique puis de stratégie
économique monsieur fils jaden rappelle
souvent le panier bleus mais on l'amène
pas un point transactionnel encore pour
l'instant nicolas vous en pensez quoi du
panier bleus six mois plus tard mais moi
je dis que le panier bleus c'est ce
qu'on avait besoin en 2005
aujourd'hui avoir une vitrine ou avoir
un répertoire de commerçants ça
s'appelle bourges pays où même les pages
jaunes
on n'a pas besoin de ça il faut des
actions concrètes pour amener nos
commerçants a mené les entrepreneurs
gère le 21e siècle c'est qu'on pense que
ça prend presque cinq jours des fois
envoyé quelque chose de montréal à
québec ça coûte 30 dollars
comment ça c'est que quand j'achète
quelque chose dont amazon est là comment
ça se fait qu'on n'investit pas dont 6
internet haute vitesse qui est tellement
important voire région on est à montréal
l'internet pas bien mais en région si tu
veux une boutique en ligne puis ton
internet arrête pas de tomber je parle
aux à l'entrepreneur françois lambert sa
de tomber à son chalet à sa ferme six ou
sept fois par jour il est en train de
devenir fou et que la logistique le
transport il faut que ça aille plus vite
il faut que ça ce que les coûts soient
plus bas il faut vraiment rentré dans le
21e siècle pagny bleus c'est génial mais
sur google rôle trouble le danois dans
les annonces du journal local ombre
auquel quel commerce
est-ce que c'est utile le panier bleus
pour vous de diamant pour moi c'est une
offensive marketing le panier bleus
c'est juste pour attirer l'attention le
ce qui est vraiment intéressant du
panier parce que c'est pas son objectif
d'attirer l'attention mais découvrir des
commerces
non ça c'est un peu tout seul il faut il
faut des actions concrètes derrière la
seule chose qui était intéressant du
panier bleus au niveau de l'avenir c'est
les huit chantiers qui débutent cet
automne parce que quand on regarde le
panier blues qui est intéressant c'est
que huit chantiers qui démarre sur
l'avenir du commerce de détail
et là on se pose les vraies questions
par exemple les appellations québécoise
comment va on va parler comment on va
mettre des labels des labels sous les
produits québécois
ensuite la capacité numérique comment on
fait pour que les petits détaillants
puisse prendre le virage numérique
ensuite bon nicolas n'a parlé le
transport la livraison amazon est établi
des précédents tout le monde s'attend à
voir ses produits dans les 24 heures
donc comment on fait pour que les petits
détaillants québécois puissent faire la
même chose ya des projets entre autres
de livraison à vélo dans les zones
urbaines denses qui sont super
intéressant et le dernier chantier
comment on change les habitudes donc au
fond le fait changer les habitudes des
détaillants changer les habitudes des
consommateurs
c'est pas avec un répertoire qu'on va
changer les habitudes des traces et
paniers bleus qui va faire cette
consultation hisser le panier bleus qui
met à nu est chantier pour tous les
automnes et trouver des solutions dans
huit chantiers moi j'en ai deux mais
quatre qui met la tête particulièrement
et c'est ça qui est intéressant parce
que le répertoire c'est juste une
offensive pour attirer l'attention mais
c'est les chantiers c'est le travail qui
doit être fait dans ces chantiers le que
j'ai vraiment important mais c'est ce
qu'ils auraient dû faire dès le départ
ses huit chantiers là effectivement ce
excellence j'en aurais peut-être
remplacer un pour un autre mais peu
importe
mais c'est le répertoire qui doivent
leur prendre et une immensité de temps à
remplir
vingt-deux mille commerçants lieu de
tout de rien là dedans c'est vraiment
important que le gouvernement ne
prennent pas la place de l'entrepreneur
l'entrepreneur c'est sa job de se faire
connaître
cependant il doit avoir et de pouvoir
aller à la guerre avec les bons outils
si le port ethernet aussi un internet de
ouais ça marche si si on devait arriver
un site transactionnel le panier bleus
est ce qu'on arrivera donc à ce moment
là quelque chose de beaucoup plus
efficace selon vous ses rayons si on n'a
pas réglé tous les enjeux en arrière
vers moi ce qui me trouble c'est que je
suis la cliente cible du panier bleus
j'ai mes armoires remplies de produits
québécois mais gardera
rapide produits québécois mais je suis
allé deux fois sur le site une fois
l'ouverture par curiosité puis une fois
aujourd'hui pour la chronique je suis
pas allé sur le site dont quelque chose
qui me trouble dans ce pourquoi moi la
cliente la cliente yves je vais pas sur
le panier bleus quelque chose de
troublant est ce qu'on aurait pu
dépenser les 3 millions aujourd'hui du
gouvernement ailleurs de manière plus
efficace nicolas oui effectivement
et puis pour revenir sur le pas des
lieux et puis sur le fait est que ce
gouvernement qui devrait aller vers le
transactionnel maintenant il ya déjà un
site web transactionnel de propriété
québécoise qui offrent des produits
québécois on est attisée amazon québec
l'autriche s'est pas vraiment de notre
sport ça se parle la maison de québec
pions on va en parler objectivement
parce que c'est intéressant
diane bérard nicolas duvernois vous êtes
passionné à la semaine prochain à la
semaine prochaine bonne soirée